so hi first I'd like to check the
microphone is it okay okay so yeah let's
jump into it so I'd like to tell you
about my experience with respect to two
things which are pretty similar but they
are not the same so the first I'd like
to tell you about my impression on
uncertainty in machine learning and how
to tackle it using chocolate estimation
using bias on neural networks so this is
the topic of my presentation so first
let me briefly introduce myself so
currently I work for sigmoid Oh which is
consult my machine learning artificial
intelligence consider consultants in
boutique here in Warsaw I work there as
principal machine learning engineer and
beside that I also work in the student
scientific group which is called tensor
traffic we use passion machine learning
there so this is one of the sources of
my thoughts here beside of that I
currently work for over three years in
business and over one and a half year I
use bias and deep learning so this is
like my base which I'd like to share
today okay
so let me briefly outline what I would
like to tell you about today so first I
would start from a certainties so I will
show you examples and how they differ
because there is no not single
uncertainty but there are different
kinds of them then I will briefly show
you the basics of Bayesian machine
learning then will gentle gently dive
into by ocean deep learning and at the
end I will show you something
interesting from for you which I found I
found it recently entered thinking this
is really really interesting because
this shows somehow that machine learning
actually just filled the cycle in some
way and is also connected to bash and
deep learning okay so let's start how
many of you have heard about this issue
that the apple face ID used
since the iPhone X was hacked yeah so
this was really popular issue which
showed that actually we can hack machine
learning and there is always an
interesting risk in machine learning in
if you consider this case from my
perspective it's not the algorithm to
blame if you build better I'll do it
that will certainly will be people who
try to hug them and it's almost
impossible that in as time goes to
infinity that no one will hug this
algorithm so there is always a risk in
machine learning and this is also might
be considered as kind of uncertainty so
this is the first case of uncertainty
which I'd like to cover the second thing
is a little bit different how many of
you have heard about this case yet this
is really funny actually maybe of the
rails a little bit but so the situation
looked looks the following sexually
Microsoft Research released a Twitter
bot where they'll taught the bot to
response to the Twitter and obviously
they online train them during the
conversation and after some time someone
realized that this bot actually really
got off the rails and started to and
started being really nasty so I think
this is a completely different kind of
risk and uncertainty than the preview on
here actually what happened is that the
model went of the experience which
researchers taught him on right so it
was introduced by obviously malicious
but new data and this new data
completely chess which the model so it
turned out that there were there were
kinds of data for which this model
wasn't robust to in the first place okay
so let's wrap this up so we have two
kinds of uncertainties right so here so
let's have a look at this graph so what
do we have here so imagine that you have
ideal classifier right so this
classifier disc remains between cats and
dogs
and this is ideal one you cannot build
better one based on for example images
so the orange orange line is the score
for cat for dogs and the blue one is for
cuts and the green one is the sum of
these lines so obviously you will always
have a risk right even in case of the
best classification there is there will
always be a region which would be hard
to classify and there is second kind of
error where you don't have simply you
don't have enough data but you can have
more right if and if you have more data
so for example if the researchers which
were developing the bot knew about this
malicious attack they could tackle it so
it's so here this is something which
based on our data we cannot tackle and
this we call a risk or a logic error and
we have something which is got a piste
emic error which can be tackled in case
of what if we get more data right okay
so this is the this part where we talk
about uncertainties and why the next
part is about Bayesian deep learning
because nowadays brush and the planning
is one of the most important most widely
used techniques in order to assess as
different kinds of uncertainties in deep
learning
so this now obviously there are other
method methods I will briefly cover them
at the end of my presentation but now
let's dive into version machine learning
okay so before we get into it I would
like to show you a comparison between
classical machine learning and by ocean
machine learning I did it in the form of
points where we compare different stage
of trainings in both of these approaches
and it's slightly adjusted to neural
nets so it's not like the general
machine learning but it's likely
adjusted to neural networks so in the
classical machine learning when you
train your network you have we call it
topology right we have something to
which we feed the data and we get the
model so it consists of modern
architecture model weights etc
so at the beginning we have a set of all
possible models whereas in Bayesian
machine learning we have something more
because beside this set we have a
distribution of various models so we can
say okay this model is more likely than
this one right so this is the first
difference and this probability
distribution is often called prior when
it comes to optimization usually we'd
like to build a model and most of the
current deep learning models might be
expressed in these terms where we
maximize the likelihood of data right so
we take a model and we choose a single
model which will maximize with respect
to what we'd like to optimize it whereas
in violation machine learning we we are
not training a single model but we are
changing the distribution right we'd
like to this new distribution which
occurs during the optimization process
to like be more likely to produce our
data in some sense so this is the second
change and this is also covered in the
second point so actually the third where
here we have usually a deterministic
function so we have a single function
whereas here we have once again model
distribution so it's from this sense is
completely different what is really
worthy to state here that usually we
cannot tackle this distribution so in
some sense we are approximating this
distribution using samples a set of
samples which we can produce from this
distribution and during the inference if
you have a function we are calling the
function if I have a distribution and
we'd like to have an inference we need
to average this distribution out in some
sense so these are the differences right
and where the uncertainty comes from
from to actually point points two and
three actually shows where we can assess
what is the uncertainty of our
distribution of models because if these
distribution has like huge variance then
one may assume that we are pretty
uncertain about our answers right and if
the or for example if the inference when
we average out
distribution varies and have huge
variance this is also the implication
that's we cannot be probably 100% sure
about the inference of our model so
obviously these two things are somehow
similar so basically if we have the same
models we have the same inferences
whereas the opposite usually doesn't
hold because we could we could have
similar inferences made by different
different different models and actually
these uncertainty in parameters because
this is how it's actually called it's
harder to assess because of the fact
that it's very often intractable so
usually we will stick to these inference
distribution the predictive distribution
and we'll simply check whether this
predictive distribution is pretty
certain or not so during the rest of
presentation I will assume that will
rather refer to the inference
distribution okay so here is an example
so this is an example of linear
regression and here we you have a tract
of classical machine learning here you
have tract of Bayesian machine learning
so in case of violation you have a
prayer here so the problem which we are
solving here is within our regression
with two parameters W 1 and W 2 and here
you can see samples from the because we
can sample the models right so here the
models are lines so here you may see the
sample from the distribution so the
Apriori if we have only prior assumed a
see who did this prior here is a
gaussian one so we assume that our
parameters comes from 0 centered
Gaussian and what's worth to know worth
to notice at this stage that here you
have like plus signs here and this is
like the original distribution that the
grant true distribution and as you may
see here when the new data arrives
actually D this we can see that this new
distribution of parameters is actualized
and we have like and it's more and more
certain in this case whereas in case of
classical machine learning due to
different in variances in parameters the
situations still like you
a huge region of valid models which
highly differs from from the grunt truth
one so this example which I took from
Christopher beshal book shows you
somehow why one may be interested in
using Bayesian learning okay so this is
how it looks like from machine learning
point of view but obviously we'd like to
tell about the deep learning and deep
learning inference so I will make a
maybe short let me troduce my approach
to this part so what I wanted to achieve
here by presenting this part I will not
use n equations I want simply to share
with you my thoughts and intuitions
which I found extremely useful when I
was reading these papers about passion
machine learning and I'd like to show
you how I usually approach these new
methods and what I think makes them much
easier to understand and implement so
that's why for example in something
which is called the variational lower
bound which if how many of you is
familiar with this with this concept
yeah it's really hard one from the
mathematical perspective so I'd like to
share like simplified intuition behind
this so when you will once you would
read the paper once you read the paper
you will understand steps which are
happening there so in case of neural
networks even shallow one it's not the
case that only did the only deep neural
networks are hard but obviously the
deeper one the harder the problem is we
have something do to do like many
nonlinearities which occur in the
inference of neural network
this makes the like computing the closed
form of this posterior like we had here
almost impossible and it's really really
hard just to give you an example before
the deep learning era when we so for
example in Christopher bishops book
there is an example of how to
how one can apply biasion methods to two
neural nets not deep learning so there
are eight really harsh assumption made
in order to make it happen so it's
really really hard right and there is a
single single trick which makes it a
little bit easier and I'd like to
introduce with this trick which is
called the variational lower bound so
what's happening here is that okay
we have neural network models so we have
the distribution of models and it's
obviously once the data arrives it's
impossible to compute the posterior of
this data so what one can do so first of
all one can introduce the second
distribution called Q here which is easy
to sample we can easily get samples from
this distribution so we can take this
distribution and sample let's say 100
different models from it and have have
these particular realizations in order
to for example train them and during the
training we are doing two things so
first of all we like to have have this
queue penalized for differing from prior
so we would like to say okay I'd like
you to produce similar models as I am so
when I buy I mean I mean prior but on
the other hand on these samples which
are relatively easy to sample we'd like
to perform the original training so this
is as simple as that we have two steps
here so first of all we are sampling
models we can do this per training per
batch usually multiple approaches are
taken and then we'd like to once this
model is trained we'd like to make these
parameters not to differ from prior a
lot so as you may see and many papers
are actually following which uses
variational lower bound actually follows
this idea and I will show you later how
this looks like
and during the inference okay once again
we can sample these models so during the
inference once the training is finished
we can sample from the distribution
queue and have a sample from this
distribution
we can approximate different statistical
measures in order to perform prediction
uncertainty estimation etc so assume I
see here it's rather predictions of the
samples models valid because of the fact
that usually the parameters of
narrowness are so complicated and have
so many multiple in variances that it's
hard to say that okay these different
models are totally different okay so how
one can think about this variational
lower bound I'd like to think about this
as projection we have posterior
distribution and we have subspace of
easy to compute and easy to sample
distributions so we are projecting our
posterior distribution on this simple
one okay so let me give you a few
examples of how this works so first of
all we have it's one of the simplest and
it's but on the other hand really
popular so how many of you have heard
about dropout okay so for for the rest
the dropout is a technique where during
the training you are with each of these
units you have assigned the probability
and you in depend independently turn off
these units with respect to this
probability so for example if this unit
has probability of 0.3 in in ten
different runs of this algorithm
it will be probably something like four
times turned off during the inference
during the training and variation our
dropout comes from the fact that you
keep this procedure going during the
inference phase so you can sample
multiple models from it so this is I
think one of the simplest examples of
the variational training so how this
looks like so first of all we have like
two popular kinds of methods here so
first of all is vanilla one where we
have a fixed for each unit we have a
fixed dropout rate during the whole
training and inference so as you may see
here these distribution doesn't change
so we don't penalize it because it's
it's constant and it actually produces
pretty good results but for the risk
only and there is actually I came across
a really interesting and simple
explanation why this happens
so because the distribution this
distribution of this turning of the
units probabilities doesn't change if
you for example so one expects that if
doubles it data set that you're the
model should be more certain with
respect to the epistemic impressive
uncertainty but what if if this doesn't
change if we double the our data set
it's almost equivalent to train your
network for twice as many books as with
the original one so this is a simple
explanation why this is only risk not as
epistemic uncertainty so in order to
tackle that one can use concrete dropout
when these dropout rate is actually
learn about but beware that this might
be hard and unstable unstable in
training on the other hand it's really
really interesting technique so here you
may see example so we'd like to train a
model based on simple function like when
you have a same single argument a single
output so as you may see here this is
the technique which I will cover later
and it shows that for example okay we
have ten points so we are pretty
uncertain what happens outside that this
word up where we don't have points but
once we have more points we are more and
more certain but in case of dropout as
you may see so these three area here I
think it's this is the plot of the
confidence intervals with respect to the
score so as you may see here once the
more of more if the more point more more
points arrives arrive the uncertainty
estimation that our our uncertainty
estimate doesn't change so that's why I
truly advise you to use the vanilla drop
out only for the risk assessment the
second technique which is also which I
also found relatively simple but also
interesting is a technique which is
called bias by back prop it's not a
single technique even in this paper
where you have it's implemented you have
multiple versions of models there but I
will
stick myself to the simplest one so this
technique is actually comes from the
family which is widely used of these
buyers and deep learning models which
use something which is called latent
Gaussian variables and how this works so
let me show you on a simple example so
we'd like to have distribution of our
weights not single set of weights so how
can we get the distribution otherwise
instead of single weights so we can
treat a single weight here as a sum of
normally distributed random variable
multiplied by the positive factor here
actually this is the variance right so
of this distribution which is learnable
because this parameter is learnable plus
the mean of this distribution so as you
may see here these latent variables are
these ones and we treat and we simply
were simply something during the
inference time we're something this this
realization of the random variable
independently for each way and then we
transmit transform using these learnable
parameters and that's how we obtain the
distribution over over a single weight
so there are a few problems with this
because once again it's rather believed
to be good at propagation of risk and
why is that so first of all all of these
variables are independent right and
there are also independent of target and
this is crucial because let's consider a
single model where we have a target Y
which is normal random variable with
mean with some mean and with some
variance and we have a random variable X
by which we'd like to approximate this
target one so if you think about it
closely if you want this approximation
to be good with respect to for example
the mean squared error you'd like like
the difference of these two
distributions to have 0 mean and small
variance right but this equals because
of this fact because of the fact that
these variables are independent this
makes your trainable distribution here
to set the
variance to zero because if because of
the independence because if this
trainable distribution have positive
variance it will add its variance to the
prediction and will increase the
variance so that's why this is like
brief explanation why these meters
actually doesn't propagate uncertainties
during the training it rather propagates
the risk because this if the the
prediction change this means that these
changes actually change something so
this was a region which was uncertain
but it was rather uncertain because of
the fact that different different
predictions came from the same argument
and that's why this distribution was
uncertain not the fact that these points
were unknown to distribution as I show
in the preview graph so this is the
explanation why these methods might
might fail and actually they are failing
which for example deepmind researchers
notice in their work on reinforcement
learning so it's not like this this is
rather a simple explanation of empirical
fact which was observed rather than a
mathematical explanation which is which
is abstract okay so these were mad
meters which were using latent Gaussian
variables so in the end I'd like to show
you something really fresh really new
this came from paper this was introduced
by paper which I already stated here
randomised Perl functions for deep
reinforcement learning this paper was
published in in June this year and I
really like it because first of all it's
proof that it's really good and on the
other hand I think this is a model which
someone could came up with like ten
years ago because it uses like old-style
methods so actually how this method
works so first of all it's really good
because it can make Bayesian any neural
network if you have it trained and what
is good it's for regression most of
these methods which I presented they're
rather good
classification please method started
good for regression as like as I said
this came from deep mind which is
interested in estimate in estimation of
reward which is continuous so you take
the model and you take the K copies of
this model buy buy buy copies I mean the
same architecture but random weights
then you sum for each of these models
you subset or in bootstrap a subset of
your original data set for each of these
subsets you perturb the target using the
Gaussian noise and then for each of
these copies of the original model you
train it to predict the difference
between the perturbed target and the
original model and during the inference
one may treat you take the original
model take each of the assemble models
you add them because as you may see then
this will cancel out and you can treat
these as samples from the posterior and
for some reason this works really well
actually it's called by ition because
this procedure is equivalent to
polishing to position one in case of
linear regression so it's not strictly
by asian but this is the Russian Allah
provided and it works really well and if
you are familiar with methods like which
were popular like 10-15 years ago I
think this is one this could be easily
developed during this time so in some
sense in the in case of by Asian deep
learning the machine learning made the
full cycle and we are coming back to
good ol meters like bootstrap target
perturbation etc I found this really
really interesting ok so this was the
last part just to show you how this why
how this works so here is this method
where you have this pure network and
bootstrap as you may see so this is a
really interesting example so here you
have so the data set consists of a set
of a set of points with constant value
and one additional point with totally
different value and when they think
whether this come from bias or this came
from like new trend which is not
observed yet so as you may see the
classical assemble
which we was trained on the full data
it's not doesn't capture the the
uncertainty simply the same happens for
single assemble and prior Network but in
case of bootstrap there were models
which which which haven't captured this
point and as you may see the
bootstrapping and the pro network
actually makes these predictions to be
more uncertain which matches our
expectation that we don't know what will
happen here so we'd like to check we
don't know whether these points actually
start a new trend for example the
concert 1 or this is a simple simple
bias so as you may see this is an
example how this method works like just
the final slide because I haven't
covered everything because infer to me
is hard to do this in 30 minutes so if
you are interested in that so here these
two methods are like state-of-the-art
methods like really really hard actually
this one is really hard to understand
what is true it's really it's really
powerful and this one is also came from
deep mind this huge variational lower
bound method this one is also really
interesting because one may tackle the
assessing uncertainty as checking
whether the active inner activation of
network is known so for example one we
can take the inner activation on
training set we can build some kind of
density model let's check whether the
new point actually matches the
distribution so here you may find the
paper which shows this approach this
approach I put this paper this is a
pretty new put in your approach and it's
I think slowly emerging on on this fake
set of ideas because all of these
methods they need either multiple
training multiple inferences so the
meters for example my method which
actually needs a single forward pass are
getting more and more popular because of
the speed issue and if you want to see
the implementations of like these two
methods you can go to this github
repository and I think something like
month ago I gave similar speech but I
considered it mostly on uncertainty so
if you want to see get know more about
as
certainty and how to tackle it in a
simple way you can go here where you
have all of materials from my preview
table that's all thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you much in we have space for one
question no questions
oh there's one sorry just like you
mentioned basically new models 4x4
training neural networks which
incorporate some Bayesian inference but
are there any advances in efficient
sampling techniques that come useful
today or is it mostly from designing new
models actually these two met these two
meters here they're actually they're
rather increasing the complexity of
something then the model one the models
one so you can take actually almost
every any model any neural network model
and you can change this model by
introducing like really complex
something using these techniques so
these techniques are actually rather
about sampling then about the neural
network architectures or models thank
you so much great applause Martin
[Applause]